hey everybody this is International
master David proofs for chess calm and
today I'll be introducing one of the
main defenses for black against efore
namely the caro-kann now the Karl Khan
is most similar to the French these are
two openings in which black instead of
trying to prevent white from playing d4
tries to challenge the white pawn on e4
by placing a black pawn on d5 okay so
White's goal here if black played a
silly move like a six would be to play
d4 so the four best defenses to e4 two
of them are to prevent white from
playing d4 by controlling that square
with a pawn and two of them are to allow
d4 but answer would d5 challenging the
white pawn in the center so you can
prepare that with the e6 or c6 so here's
the caro-kann c6 and definitely the main
move for white d4 black plays d5 and you
see his plan is to set up a strong pawn
in the center challenge the white pawn
and deal with White's space advantage in
the center immediately this way now the
carl khan has at least two good things
about it the stronghold in the center
which i've just pointed out and the fact
that black hasn't really given up much
in terms of development he has taken
away one square from his knight but if
you contrast that with the French
defense the French defense has far
longer reaching impacts on the bishop on
c8 then the carl khan has on the knight
on b8 which still can get out through
two different routes so those are the
nice things about the carl khan the one
thing that's a little bit not the
easiest about the carl khan to play is
that white has a huge range of ways that
he can play against the carl khan and so
if you want to learn the carl khan you
actually have to be prepared for a
variety of approaches from white and I
will quickly list them for you here but
each of them will get its own video as
well
okay so just listing them one thing you
have to be ready for is the main line
where white will play Knight c3 or 92
defending the pawn on e4 and after you
captured he takes back on e4 now you get
a smooth development for your bishop if
you want and then you follow up with e
six at some point and black has a solid
position no weaknesses and room for all
his pieces but white still has a little
space advantage and often a nagging
little advantage for white that's one
type of position you have to be able to
play a second type of position you have
to be able to play is the advanced
variation where white gains more space
by advancing this pawn here defended by
the pawn on d4 easily defended by the
pawn on c3 as well and taking away this
square from your knight and cramping
your King side generally now the good
thing about this compared to the
advanced French is that your bishop can
come out but you have to be a prepared
to play this kind of a d4 d5 pawn chain
as well another option for white is not
to play d4 on move two but to play d3
and then on d5 to play a king's immune
attack and they're coming with g3 and
Bishop g2 now white you can play that
against almost any defense for black so
you need to know something about this or
be comfortable playing this position no
matter what you want to play another
option for white is to play the two
Knights variation where he just brings
out his knight and doesn't yet commit
his pawn to d4 or d3 and this is has
some of its own independent and
interesting positions possible that you
need to be ready to play as well and
back to d4 d5 white has three more
options for how to play this position
here that are significant one is to take
take and place c4 pressuring d5 and in
this position here as you can imagine at
some point these pawns will probably be
traded leaving white with an isolated
Queen pawn which is its own whole style
of chess play so that's another big
option y can also trade on d5 but not
follow up with c4 and instead just play
the slightly more clothes
formation with Bishop d3 pawn to c3 and
Knight f3 and castling and this exchange
variation is also playable for white and
finally the last major option for white
against the car Khan is f3 the fantasy
variation where he tries to maintain his
pawn on e4 at the cost of his Knights
development but one of the things in the
con is it's not easy for black to win
the fight for e4 so white can set up
something with Knight c3 and Bishop e3
or Bishop f4 and maintaining this Center
and then it's complicated and there are
lots of different pollen structures that
can still come out of this position here
so really the caro-kann is considered
very good defense to e4 it's become
popular of late and black seems to be
doing well with it but one issue for
people want to take it up is that you're
going to have to be ready for a huge
variety of different positions or you
might enjoy that because that makes
chess more fun and exciting I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm